Some key moments behind everything.
Will you rate your film? Can I do that? Please take a look at the film. Oh, scoring. Okay,
click go first or... I did terrible. I could totally tell what I did wrong.
Okay, back to the presentation. Yes. Your pattern is scored based on the number 10. So out of 10
is your mark. As you can see, it's split up into two parts. We have our accuracy
and our presentation on this side. So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a four. So from the number four,
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern. And then with that one,
any mistakes that you made, whether it's a minor mistake, yet a minus of a 0.1,
if it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3. So I'll just let you guys know about the difference
between the two. So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing. So say we're doing a
out of block. If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a
tiny bit higher. That's a minor mistake. So that's a 0.1. A major mistake would be you're supposed to
do an out of block in the pattern, but you forget and you say you do a rich hand stroke instead.
So that would be a major mistake. So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern one, for example,
there's 20 steps. It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns,
sorry, the 20 steps. So the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to get,
to not get a deduction of 0.1. So it's not uncommon, let's say there's 20 steps,
and you made, let's say 15 mistakes. So what would that be? We'll leave that there on this
side and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the squat at the end. So a major mistake, say
you're supposed to turn to the left when you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake. So
obviously we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes. So after we've done our pattern,
that's when we move on to the presentation side. So the presentation, as you can see,
we're going to start off with a score of six. This six is actually split up into three parts.
So we have one, two, three here. So with this one, for a score of two is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out of two
as well. So we'll start off with the power and speed. So with this one, whether it's your blocks,
your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything you are that you do, it needs to be nice and strong,
to be fast as well. So it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch,
but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category. So the next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern. It's not just
really fast all the way through. It's not slow all the way through. There's a slow, fast, slow,
fast kind of aspect to it as well. So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also
scored out of two. The last bit is your expression of energy. So what is expression of energy? So
that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well. It's really fast and it's strong. Your rhythm is
really great, but you're not shouting very loud. Or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of
tell you're not really confident. You're a little bit nervous. So that's what we need to kind of
improve on.
So I'll just come around to this side. So with this one, for colour belts and black belts,
it's actually scored a little bit differently. So if you're a colour belt, your average,
so where the judges actually mark you from, it's actually from a 1.1. So this is your average. So
say you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else, your score for 1, 2 and 3,
it'll start from a 1.1. So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to,
say for your power and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9. If you did really great,
you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4. So each individual category, you need to obviously get
as high as you can. If you're a black belt, generally depending on the competition,
you will be scored from a 1.3. So 1.3 would be your average
that you start from. So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4
for now. Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3,
but let's say you didn't shout very loud, so your expression of energy, your average was 1.3,
it might go up to say, let's say a 1.0.
With this one, we'll come over down to this slide. So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of
10. So let's see, for presentation we had 0.7, 1, 2, 3, so you had a 3.7. And so you made 15 mistakes.
So with this one, obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
All right.
So this is with the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel and each judge, obviously
it's very subjective. So from their point of view, you might've made a lot of mistakes or you may
may have made not a lot of mistakes as well. So that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well.
Okay. So say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes. So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be
1.5. So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5. So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation, like before, we're saying we've got a 3.7 here. So we add these
numbers at the, after the judges are finished scoring. So you would get for this pattern,
a 6.2, which is actually very good. So I'll just talk about a little bit more now,
about this number here. So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above and you do
your patterns, it's not uncommon generally for a color belt. The average is about a four to five.
So if you get a number between four and five out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually
generally considered pretty good. So anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say, because we're talking here about the higher
presentation as an average, anything from five to six is actually considered pretty good. And
anything over a seven is actually considered almost world-class. So if you get a seven
for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back, you did an amazing job.
We just went through our pool day scoring. So just remember accuracy is a 4.0, presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judged during your pattern, presentation is after, and then we get
two scores that we add up and we get that number. So with this one, obviously say I was, I was judge
number one, I would give you a 6.2. There was another judge on the other side, maybe he saw
six than I did. And maybe this one would be a little bit lower. It might be a five point something.
Another judge on the other side, they scored a little bit higher. So we'd get the three numbers
and then we'd average that as well. So I hope this helped you guys. So make sure you enjoy your
cool. I got a lesson out of this. Now I need a piece of paper to watch my video again. Okay.
Practice reading.
This curve is saying my use pattern manager.
Oh, so, okay. So minor errors, major errors.
Oh, okay.
You're going to watch.
Can I watch my performance? Okay.
And then this time we cannot pause.
Oh yeah. We cannot pause.
But I can just go like whatever, right?
Yeah. Okay.
And then this one.
Okay. So after the poomsae, you're going to be
rating your power and speed coordination for the, an expression of energy.
Oh my gosh.
And then you click continue. The scores are going to be calculated automatically.
Oh, cool.
So
So each minor, okay. So when I go like that, it'll be minus 0.01 each time, right?
So if you see a minor error plus, yeah.
Like that. So does how many errors you got?
How many errors you got.
Oh, okay. Got it. Okay. Sorry. I was just like, which way are we doing this? Okay.
Yes.
Okay. Perfect. All right. Oh my God.
I already need to tell.
I need to tell you now that you know this is going to be a hard lesson.
Okay.
You'll get this done.
Um, I'll do it again.
Do it again?
Okay.
All right.
I'm just going to take you back to the pocket space.
Okay.
So you're going to take a little more time to get this done.
I'm going to give you a little more time to do this.
All right.
Okay.
You're going to hold it in.
Hold it in.
I'm going to hold it in.
We're going to sit like this.
Nice and steady.
I'm going to stand up.
Going to sit.
Good.
I know you do this.
Good job.
not right spot oh rhythm how do i do it wait
but that's wrong that's wrong i almost fell
one two three oh that's ugly
oh yikes
i'm gonna see this because on the left side i did this thing okay okay and then i go here